team getting on the team coach in  watford  just outside their hotel there we know  that the coach is on the way  to london heading for wembley probably  not far  away now but you can see there  we were seeing some helicopter pictures  before but they are pictures from on the  ground giving a wave there  to the hundreds of uh fans that we saw  gathered outside uh so that was uh  pictures from this calvin phillips at  front of that  um that was a while ago  but it's the first time of course we've  been able to see some close-up pictures  phil  foden there with his blonde mop  and i'm very unlikely to start isn't he  because of that  knot he had yesterday's gareth southgate  was telling us all right well uh the  team  will arrive in wembley soon and it is  not just england galvanizing of course  for  tonight's game italian fans watched from  as far  as their team prepared to take to the  field at  wembley